no man no man no woman should put with
bad sex and if a man is having bad sex
it's the woman's fault
it's the woman's fault because if you
get a man a male virgin and a woman
he's gonna have bad sex anyway she's
gonna teach him rubbish just to keep him
down there but if you get a man who's
had lots of sex and a virgin he's gonna
teach everything he knows to make sure
that she can perform properly so as far
as I'm concerned if you're with somebody
and you're not getting good sex from
them I'm not talking about making love
because when audiences making up making
up that's the little Christmas birthdays
whatever men is when I have sex after
sex ain't good get rid because I'm sorry
but there's too many men out there
having sexist relationships and it's
wrong
all these feelings about oh I want that
personality I want this and that